an entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship
absolutely yeah jada pinkett smith put
the word
entanglement on the map during her
latest red table talk
and on tuesday t.i poked fun at the new
buzzword in a sweet birthday message to
his wife
tiny and that's what matters the rapper
shared
this pic of his lady on her 45th b day
writing in part
we found so many different ways to
celebrate you and your magnificent
existence
and this one shall be no different may
nothing hurtful harmful or dangerous
interrupt this lifetime entanglement
just had to yeah that entanglement talk
is a clear nod to jada's recent chat
with her hubby of 22 years
will smith we ride together we gotta go
together
bad marriage for life
in case you missed it the two got really
candid about their marriage
you and i were going through a very
difficult time
yeah and we decided i was done with you
yeah you kicked me to the curb done with
you
yeah marriages have that though
marriages have that yeah we basically we
broke up
and the 48 year old actress confirmed
singer august alcina's bombshell claim
that they were romantically involved in
the past
while will and jada were separated we
decided that we were going to
separate for a period of time and you go
figure out how to make yourself happy
and i'll figure out how to make myself
happy that's when jada said she got into
an entanglement with the 27 year old
and will pressed her to say what it
really was
i got into an entanglement with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely
but anyway back to ti and tiny i think
it's wonderful
the couple who tied the knot in 2010
celebrated tiny's big day with a private
beachside dinner
the rapper shared this video on
instagram writing
flew all the way to cocoa beach just to
eat
okay now that is romance back in 2013
t.i told e.t the secret sauce to making
it work
everything is day by day everything day
to day we stay together a lot
fast forward to april 2020 tiny gushed
that their marriage is better than ever
we've been like very loving
and trying to work with each other i'm
not saying we don't have spats here and
there you know but
of course we it's been like a real
close-knit
fun like uh like we back in love like
old time when we first got together so
you know that is you know really good
because we've been able to find
ourselves back into that
to that place and i think that's a a
very hard thing to do it's like
fresh new love